it's not locked down but it feels like
the country's staying at home businesses
forced to shut without the staff to open
a million people now self-isolating as
omicron takes hold
hospitals in bristol and across the
country in a critical situation and
asking for extra help the disruption
runs to the railways train departure
boards empty and a government trying to
ease the pressure with new policies to
try to keep the country moving changes
to testing lifting the burden for people
traveling to the uk
scrapping pcrs for some who test
positive on lateral flows
are you gambling with the nhs prime
minister
tough decisions to deal with logistical
pressures around the uk
the pm back to parliament hoping to turn
a corner but the political pressure not
letting up either
in response to the latest data the
cabinet agreed this morning that we
should stick with plan b for another
three weeks with a further review before
the regulations expire on the 26th of
january this government does not believe
we need to shut down our country again
instead we are taking a balanced
approach using the protection of the
boosters and the plan b measures to
reduce the spread of the virus a balance
that risks pushing the nhs over the edge
in the most difficult of winter months
the opposition bench is unconvinced the
prime minister said we have to ride out
this omicron wave
but the nhs isn't surfing it's
struggling to stay afloat prime
minister's central approach to ride out
the omercon wave is a reckless gamble
that risks lives and risks to nhs but
his own side from a former pm to a
former chief whip not entirely satisfied
either
it is not in the national interest
to partially or wholly shut down sectors
of our economy every time we see a new
variant we have got to have a plan
to live with this virus
like normal forever
when is he going to set that plan out in
this house
constantly changing rules leaving the
public here in birmingham frustrated and
skeptical too you should probably have
another lock down by now or
at least be doing more than what they
are to stop it spreading but it seems to
me that he's not doing anything to stop
his spreading if anyone watched a press
conference yesterday
uh there was no clarity in that at all
there were lots of waffling answers and
yeah it feels like a free-for-all his
agenda based on the telegraph based on
his own party
not really public opinion
and this is the dilemma boris johnson's
now facing in this place his mps don't
want any further restrictions but beyond
westminster the public mood is restless
and there are genuine fears that
hospitals could become overwhelmed with
such high levels of cases the prime
minister then pulled in two different
directions today he tried to deal with
it by changing the testing regime
instead of introducing new restrictions
but he can't be sure it's enough
mps remained desperate for an exit
strategy but with one in 10 londoners
with the virus in the last week alone
there's still no end in sight beth rigby
sky news westminster